用声音 碰撞世界 生动活泼。
生动早咖啡 与你轻松同步日常生活与商业世界。
嗨各位早上好呀 今天是二零二六年的六月十八号星期四。
这里是生动早咖啡或是来自生动活泼的梦一。
百圣中国为什么要拿下必胜课在国内的品牌所有权。
字节旗下的豆包一天能带来多少收入。
今天的早咖啡就会来回答这些问题。
当然今天是个周四。
每周四我们节目的最后都会有一杯世界杯特条。
今天要来聊聊美国人对足球的喜爱程度。
在大多数人的印象当中美国其实并不是一个热衷于足球的国家。
根据咨询公司盖洛普的统计。
从1937年到2004年只有不到2%的美国人把足球列为自己最喜欢的运动。
但是现如今这种情况正在改变。
足球的受欢迎程度甚至在美国超过了棒球。
这到底是怎么回事。
足球的热爱为什么在美国不断上升了。
我们先来了解最近发生的商业科技动态。
互不断的世界杯特条就和你一起来聊聊美国人对足球的喜爱。
百胜出售增长乏力的必胜课。
6月16号餐饮集团百胜宣布。
他们将以27亿美元的价格出售联索披萨品牌必胜课。
一家私募股权公司用15亿美元收购了中国大陆以外的必胜课业务。
肯德基在中国的运营商百胜中国。
则出资12亿美元收购了必胜课在中国大陆的品牌所有权。
交易完成之后必胜课中国将从必胜课的特许经营商。
变成品牌的所有者。
不再需要向百胜餐饮缴纳必胜课相关的特许经营费。
根据《华尔街日报》的报道。
必胜课在美国的销售额已经连续两年下滑。
百胜今年计划关闭大约250家业绩不佳的美国门店。
不过必胜课在中国的情况要衡很多。
根据《澎湃新闻》的报道。
必胜课在国内覆盖超过1100个城市。
拥有4000多家门店。
百胜中国的CEO表示。
成为品牌的所有者能够给他们带来更大的灵活性。
省下的特许经营费也能够降低开店的门卡。
沙姆中国被约谈后连换两位高管。
根据《澎湃新闻》6月17号的报道。
沙姆中国正在经历密集的管理层变动。
乌尔玛中国投资有限公司也就是沙姆的总部。
更换了董事长兼法定代表人。
新任董事长由去年10月刚刚加入。
担任沙姆会员店业态的总裁刘鹏接任。
刘鹏之前长期任职于阿里巴巴。
而在6月17号
沙姆首席采购官也由于个人的原因提交了辞程。
他将会在6月底离任。
不过乌尔玛中国对鹏派新闻表示。
工商信息变更属于正常的更新。
不涉及业务和战略的调整。
鹏派的分析认为从业绩上来看。
沙姆中国增长依然强劲。
如果计划中的门店顺利开业。
今年年底沙姆的门店数量将会达到76家。
沙姆也正在逐渐放弃此前。
雇手一线城市的开店策略。
开启下沉加速模式。
不过这种扩张速度。
在重资产长周期的仓储会员店里。
并不是很常见
沙姆的速度越来越快。
伴随的争议也越来越多。
字节AI重新转向企业服务。
根据晚点6月16号的报道。
字节跳动正在调整AI业务的资源分配。
重新从豆包这类面向大众的消费产品。
转向服务企业的产品。
豆包目前每天有超过2亿人使用。
但是一天的收入还不到100万元。
而且主要是来自于电商佣金。
同时维持豆包运行。
每天还需要消耗数千万元的算力成本。
相比之下
字节的视频生成模型ZDance。
走企业服务的路线。
年化收入已经达到了20亿美元。
差不多能够抵消豆包的算力成本。
晚点的分析认为过去半年。
Anthopy证明了AI编程。
能够让巨额的AI基建投入产生回报。
Cloud Co在去年5月上线。
收入不断的增加
让每天只有3000万用户的Anthopy。
估值充到了万亿美元。
反超美洲接近9亿用户使用的Chatchivity。
不过字节主要面向企业的ZDance。
收入增速已经有所放缓。
它的竞争对手快手可临的增长也在减速。
要让更多的行业用上AI视频生成。
还需要模型的性能继续提升。
微信测试AI支付功能。
根据界面新闻6月16号的报道。
微信支付正在联合腾讯的AI智能体产品。
BorgBody测试AI支付的功能。
微信计划在微信钱包中。
上线AI专属卡
这种卡的消费上线。
由用户充值的金额来决定。
支付的授权范围可以随时调整。
使得资金专款专用。
而且智能体发起支付的时候。
必须经过用户的确认。
有行业人士表示
目前大部分支付加AI的尝试。
还停留在交互层面。
只是让AI调用现有的支付系统。
通过对话让AI推荐下单付款。
其中由人来主导的环节还有很多。
形态上还比较出级。
而且支付的金额越大。
就越需要明确的授权和人工确认。
OpenAI去年研发支出接近200亿美元。
根据《金融时报》6月16号的报道。
财务数据显示
OpenAI在2025年的总支出。
达到340亿美元。
不过其中大约300亿的亏损。
跟OpenAI从非盈利架构转型有关。
剃除掉会计的影响。
他们的实际运营亏损在80亿美元左右。
而去年OpenAI的研发费用。
大约190亿美元。
与此同时
OpenAI还投入了大量的资金。
来进行营销
他们已经在6月初。
向美国证券交易委员会。
递交了IPO申请。
外界也预期他们的上市估值。
可能会超过1万亿美元。
不过诅透社的分析证为。
OpenAI的资源分配仍然是个问题。
比如他们在视频模型Sora上。
消耗了大量算力之后。
选择了主动关停
花费65亿美元
收购前苹果设计总监。
Johnny Ive的创业公司。
又把自己推入了
竞争激烈的硬件市场。
SpaceX600亿美元。
收购Cursor。
6月16号SpaceX宣布。
他们将会以600亿美元价值的股票。
收购AI编程工具Cursor。
这笔交易距离SpaceX。
完成上市仅仅过去了4天。
Cursor成立于2022年。
是一款帮助开发者。
通过AI生成和编辑代码的工具。
过去两年增长迅速。
根据路透社的报道。
Cursor目前来自企业客户的收入。
带约26亿美元
之前SpaceX的AI业务并不是很顺利。
这家公司在今年2月。
与马斯克创办的
AI公司XAI合并。
但是根据《纽约时报》的报道。
XAI的11位联合创始人。
已经在今年3月底之前全部离职。
马斯克本人也承认XAI需要从头重建。
在AI编程工具这个赛道上。
竞争也在加剧
Cursor的市场份额。
已经从去年6月的41%。
下滑到了今年5月的26%。
而Enthropic目前占据了。
AI编程市场一半左右的份额。
不过当天SpaceX的市值。
一度超过了亚马逊。
有分析师认为
上市给SpaceX带来了高估值的股票。
通过股票的义价
SpaceX则可以完成价值600亿美元的大型收购。
苹果将在明年推出相机版AirPods。
根据彭博社6月17号的报道。
苹果计划在2027年年底。
推出搭载摄像头的AirPods。
这款耳机将会是苹果首款。
以AI为核心的可穿带设备。
耳机饼上嵌入的摄像头。
不用来拍照录像
而是会捕捉周围环境的视觉信息。
再传送给Siri处理。
比如用户看着一堆食材。
可以直接问Siri今晚做什么菜。
这款耳机的外部还设有指示灯。
在数据上传云端处理的时候。
会发光以此来提示周围的人。
这款AirPods原计划今年发布。
但是由于苹果在AI软件上的开发进展缓慢。
同时还需要训练能够识别物体的视觉AI模型。
发布的时间也推迟到了明年。
不过苹果认为耳机作为AI可穿带设备的潜力更大。
另外相机版的AirPods。
只是苹果明年产品计划的一部分。
苹果还会发布第二代折叠屏iPhone。
和纪念iPhone问世20周年的特别版机型。
这款机型也将会配备几乎没有边框的。
曲面玻璃屏幕
深圳约谈三大外卖平台。
6月16号
深圳市场监督管理局对美团淘宝闪购。
还有京东外卖三家平台进行了集中约谈。
在前一天深圳在全市开展的执法行动当中。
发现了虚假地址
一个地址多家门店。
以及正照不服等等问题。
今年6月1号
国内开始施行关于外卖的新规定。
要求外卖平台对商家的食品经营。
许可证等等资质进行审查。
平台至少每6个月。
就需要对商户登记地址等等信息。
进行核查和更新
专门从事外卖不提供糖食的商家。
必须在主页面设置无糖食的标志。
有行业人士在接受第一财经采访的时候表示。
新规定让外卖平台变成了监管者。
而对餐饮商家来说。
会是一次合规的洗牌。
没有标准管理体系的小商家。
可能会因为成本的上升。
管理要求更高而退出。
欢迎来到今天的世界杯特条。
在美国的体育文化当中。
足球的地位一直不是很重要。
约翰霍普金斯大学的一位教授认为。
橄榄球、棒球还有篮球。
已经在美国体育版图当中占据了稳固的地位。
这几项运动几乎没有给其他的运动留下发展空间。
而且在美国文化当中。
他们喜欢得分高的运动。
但是足球进球太少。
甚至还会以平局结束。
而且美国人还更喜欢。
自己国家发明的运动。
但是根据经济学人最近的报道。
在针对美国体育爱好者的一项调查当中。
有超过10%的美国人表示。
足球是自己最喜爱的运动。
这个比例
略微超过了棒球
只落后于美式橄榄球和篮球。
现在排在第三位
那为什么足球在美国变得越来越受欢迎呢？
首先就是移民所带来的受众基础的扩大。
尼尔森的数据显示。
2024年美洲杯的决赛。
吸引了超过1200万美国观众。
创下了收视纪录
其中超过一半是拉丁意。
同一年的欧洲杯决赛。
也吸引了接近千万的美国观众。
其中40%都是拉丁意。
根据皮尤研究中心的统计。
拉丁意是美国增长速度最快的足异群体之一。
过去20多年时间里。
美国拉丁意人口几乎翻了一番。
占到了美国总人口的1.5%左右。
而足球在拉美地区一直很受欢迎。
麦肯西认为
对许多的拉丁意家庭来说。
足球不仅仅是娱乐。
还是社区和家庭生活的扭带。
全家老少往往会聚在一起看足球比赛。
除了拉丁意足群
另一个重要的原因。
就是女足带来的推动作用。
在1972年
美国通过了一项法律。
要求学校为不同性别的学生。
提供平等的参与机会。
这项法律最初关注的是性别平等。
但是却意外地促进了。
美国女子校园体育的发展。
女子足球也获得了大量奖学金。
和基础设施的资金支持。
一家智库的分析认为。
足球在当时美国的地位比较边缘。
所以女性从事这项运动的阻力。
也相对比较小
在足球强国比如英国。
足球早就被塑造成为了男性运动。
女性想要提求
要对抗的是整个文化的惯性。
但是在美国
橄榄球才是所谓的硬汉运动。
NBC的报道也显示。
足球这项运动的成本不高。
所以当学校调整体育项目的投入。
来遵循法律时
足球也是最容易让女生。
参与进来的运动之一。
1991年
赢得了首届女足世界杯的美国队。
它的主体就是美国。
北卡罗莱纳大学的校队。
当时18人的参赛大名单当中。
有一半都是来自于这所学校的。
这支球队的主教练。
同样也是由校园女足的教练来担任。
而美国女足之后
一共赢得了4次世界杯冠军。
和5枚奥运金牌
它的成功也让更多的美国人。
在关注这项运动
根据美国高中体与协会的统计。
足球是美国高中女孩。
参与度前3的运动。
有接近40万人参与。
然而最后一个原因。
也是和全球赛事内容。
涌入美国市场有关。
经济学人认为
美国流媒体平台之间的竞争。
也让足球越来越受到关注。
体育直播是少数
还能够聚集大量在线观众的内容。
广告商也愿意为此付出更高的价格。
尽管美国职业足球大联盟的。
竞技水平并不是很高。
但是苹果还是拿下了。
这个连赛的全球版权。
而且美国球迷不只看一个连赛。
而是会付费观看
从英超到西甲的全球足球赛事。
过去10年
美国媒体的足球版权支出。
增长了4倍
甚至已经超过了棒球。
那你还记得自己第一次。
看足球比赛是什么时候吗？
关于足球或者说关于世界杯。
你最早的记忆又是怎样的呢？
欢迎在我们的评论区。
和大家一起来分享。
那在今天节目的最后。
还想和你来分享一个小动态。
我们找咖啡的监制Stella。
最近完成了一次特别的采访。
这个叫Tom Hanks。
这个叫Buzz Lightyear。
喂
这个叫Tim Allen。
我叫Witty
我是Stella。
从深冻早咖啡
你好
你刚刚听到的声音。
就是来自于电影
玩具总动员系列当中的角色。
胡迪和巴斯光年的配音演员。
Tom Hanks和Tim Allen。
不久之前
他们就接受了我们早咖啡的采访。
你想知道这两位
童年声音制造者
分享了什么有趣的幕后故事。
欢迎你前往我们早咖啡的小红书。
观看我们完整的采访视频。
当然接下来我们还有更多。
和玩具总动员舞有关的内容。
想要和你分享
那今天就是我们在端午假期前的。
最后一期节目了
6月22号的一早。
我们不见不散
经典动画电影续作。
玩具总动员舞
即将在明天
也就是6月19号。
在国内正式上映
相信大家对这个系列。
应该并不陌生
自1995年第一部问事起。
玩具总动员不仅开创了。
电脑动画长篇的鲜和。
更是陪伴了全球几代人的成长。
成为许多人心中难忘的。
儿时温情记忆
在这个端午假期
备受全球影迷喜爱的玩具天团。
将在今年夏天再度合体。
小时候
玩具是开启童年想象力的钥匙。
但如今
各种科技产品进入童年世界。
悄悄占据着孩子们的注意力。
传统玩具的时代
难道真的就要结束了吗？
时隔7年
玩具总动员舞
带着同样温暖之余的底色归来。
胡迪 巴斯光年
翠丝等老朋友也将再度回归。
只不过这一次
威胁他们的不再是被遗忘的储物柜。
而是令孩子们
欲罢不能的科技玩具。
面对强劲的电子对手。
这群陪伴了邦尼
整个童年的玩具伙伴们。
还能否帮他找回
真实的快乐与友谊呢？
这个假期
不妨和家人朋友一起走进影院。
在胡迪 巴斯光年。
以及玩具新朋友们的陪伴下。
再次迎接这场关于爱。
成长与永恒陪伴的旅程。
希望大家和我们一起尊重正版。
守护原创
也提前祝大家端午节观影愉快。